e siamo giunti al record del mondo che
non vedono però abbiamo vinto io e non
vi sporchi in meno di un minuto
ovviamente era la versione con la
velocizzata di un gassman meno di un
minuto è veramente però abbiamo fatto un
disastro e buona visione guardate il
video
siamo impostori l'ultima volta sono
andate molto bene vediamo dalla marciva
subito a uccidere fair e li vediamo se
rischia di ammazzare qualcun altro che
qua non c'è una ventola quindi non me ne
posso andare step st quindi attenzione
senza la tentazione serve fermo s'è
fermato beccare qualcuno fix lights
ok quindi non si vede un cap speriamo
che con il fix lei si sia fermato da
qualche parte che sono un casino martina
che noia bayern che ha ucciso perfetto
meno male uccisi insieme ma non ho
riportato sul monitor non stai ragazzo
aperti tutti i negozi da gava 47morta
cosa devo fare voti apre proprio no non
ho visto niente ma forno di via della
canoa
bella la bellissima ragazza p tra aifa
c'è veramente la partita più veloce ma
incredibile ragazzi veramente assurda
starò abbiamo fatto velocissimo
velocissimo di nuovo che io metto
facciamo un'altra da quel momento è
normale vediamo che succede
cioè normale norma lunghezze tutto
velocizzato un casino abbiamo fatto
velocissimo disastro abbiamo fatto il
genocidio
va bene o di slides da fissare subito le
visto subito li vediamo se riusciamo
becali impostori lo fissate istantanea
vediamo march veloci e l'ex aosta nuvole
ci destiamo attenzione incredibile sia
pulito abbastanza clean
secondo me marce un sospettato perché ha
aspettato riuscire a quest'ora divieto
non gli ho dato l'appeal notte che corre
vediamo matteo fire e la che fa le cose
è morto qualcuno nate per secolo man up
però ne sono sicuro che ormai non ne
sono sicuro non ne sono sicuro però deve
essere sicuro e non mi dice
era come guarda ripetino se ha avuto
votato il bella kolber cavolo ecco no
era che usciva da weapon del demonio non
ero sicuro in favore sbagliato sbagliato
sbagliato
peccato vabbè dai no bisogna colpire
trattamento ma che partiti in uscita io
lo steccone non servono e number one
master fire che ho mancato solo un
idiota patentato
ho fatto anche la rima ma però ho anche
tentato attenzione come sono bravo io
rimango in mente prima si sa che cosa
intesa benedetta comunque se successo
eravamo in quanto da una parte ragazzo
ucciso io come e perché si tende a casa
ma cosa è successo e non lo farò una
domanda domanda ma cos'è star nota
comanda la porta dietro per la mia dico
questa mattina quella arrivata l'ora
giro certo in luce la sul mento ce l'hai
attaccata comunque non inquadra una
parte di un posto di vallata ragazzi che
noia si auto nottata ma non si capisce
per quale concedersi ma compromette qui
niente ma andiamo a fare la doppia ero
stesso ne andiamo a fare la doppia e lo
stesso ne va be che cio elettrica adesso
hanno fissato luci quindi ok al mette a
fare 94 ben che cacchio c'hanno aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto
adesso dico che adesso video porto e 6 e
porta aiuto aiuto aiuto non le porto
perché vabbè però avrei voluto
riportarli perché gli stavano seguendo e
avevo comunque alibi che mi stavano
seguendo questi due stanno insieme
stesse dove vai
ho visto che sta seguendo di se vedo
qualcuno non ho capito dove aiuto quanti
cacchio siamo ancora tanti abbiamo fatto
fuori solo uno porca vacca
l'alleggerimento di pixar della hit by
step tranquillo adesso fixer o le luci
ci stanno due insieme nat
ok allora signor forse ma visto aiuto e
non ha capito la risata di un aiuto
dall'alto ma tendono per tipo 2 minuti
ho smesso di seguirlo ed è morto
ma cosa parlare volevo mattino ma per
calare deciso io ho votato trovando
sente meno male meno male vale ragazzi è
il momento di fare la doppia non ci
siamo
1385 sono tutti là quindi teoricamente
potremmo fare la doppia march è lì che è
il punto
io metterei fix elettrica ok si sistema
vuole fare la doppia per il problema che
c'è troppa gente ok ok 354 by step dai
vai vai 32 by by step dai vai a farla
bike e m farlo fuori tu quello e non
facevi fosse fuori l'altro uno dei due
deve fare fuori qualcuno dai
la croazia manca nella sua città
dovranno uscire ragazzi non capivo chi
vuole di uccidere dei due ma che ne so
io c'è altrimenti era la doppia meno
zincata della storia terribile d'alba me
però che video vi sia piaciuto
vi auguro a tutti quanti un buon anno
visto che insomma siamo qua niente spero
spero che stiate bene vi mando un bacio
ci vediamo possibile iscrivere lasciato
un momento ma sotto che dire già
coltivati e cercherò di capire cosa fare
i possibili giudiziale con gassman i
profili da normali anche lì conosce
anche cane dischord se volete
consigliarvi qualche gioco da fare ce la
sezione apposta e noi come sempre
ragazzi ci vediamo ad un prossimo vino
beh ragazzi
[Musica]